Brian I have followed the disputations
of the Multiverse as you like to say the
Multiverse and it's discontents uh in
terms of is it a science and can we know
anything about it and if it's not a
science should we even be discussing it
and the the significance of that
question is is is a is a very
significant one it has impact really
across across all science in terms of
what can you really know can you really
know something that is the product of
theory even if you cannot detect it even
if you can't detect it maybe even in
principle right there's a fundamental
question you're an experimentalist
you're deeply involved in questions with
a Multiverse give me a sense of where we
are today where we go from here and as a
as an experimentalist what can you
contribute yeah so I've asked these
questions of none other than renowned
cosmologist Jim Peebles who won the
Nobel Prize in uh about 2019 I believe
it was and his response in a very
eloquent way he said shut up and measure
implying which I agree with actually
that our job is not to kind of add the
advocative of one of these Alternatives
or one of these paradigms but it's to
teach the controversy so to speak and I
think it's it's quite fascinating
because we could be in a highly
ambiguous state right we could come to a
point where our brilliant colleagues on
the Simon's Observatory and the bicep
team is continuing as well and that's
healthy too to have competitors in the
marketplace of experiments so let a
couple of flowers bloom at least
but we could come to a point when these
brilliant experimentalists that I get to
work with we reach a saturation point we
can't improve our technology anymore
they're already building detectors that
can't be improved upon if they're
operating on earth and the only way to
get them any better is to take them to
space and even that doesn't do that much
good
what if we get to this point where we've
winnowed down the zoo of inflationary
models and we've done tremendous we've
killed off billions and billions of of
creatures of distortions of of theorist
nightmares and but there's still an
infinite number of real numbers aren't
excluded how will science handle it when
we're in this ambiguous State humans
hate ambiguity they hate this notion of
when does Life Begin you know they hate
the notion of you know with gun control
should you have an infinite number of
guns should you have no guns
um we like black and white what if there
is no black and white resolution what if
we can't say that inflation took place
or inflation didn't take place what if
we can't say these alternative number
one didn't take place or did take if
we're in that state I don't know what
will happen in the philosophy of
cosmology I think you know on a
practical level I'll still keep teaching
you know everything by the way is
hinging upon a moment in time that's so
incomprehensibly small it's that lastly
slightly more than What's called the
plank time which is perhaps the smallest
interval of time that's even conceivable
to discuss so we're talking about a few
hundred plank times
at that level of understanding lies all
of our ignorance and it may be akin to
well how will how will you know
scientists react to the fact as they do
now we can't really know what happens
inside of Event Horizon we can have
theories but do we understand the
implications outside of it does that do
things to us in terms of our knowledge
or our philosophical dispositions I
don't know well Well here here's the
question that it seems uh
uncontroversial that that a Multiverse
is the product of our our best theory
today which is the inflation theories
that seems to be a natural consequence
of it maybe not 100 sure most people I
would think would say that
other people would say that may or may
not be true but it doesn't matter
because we can't measure a Multiverse in
principle now I'm giving you that as a
supposition suppose it is the case that
we cannot measure a Multiverse in
principle or as you say we know how to
measure it but we've gotten down to the
the absolute level of where we can
measure and we don't get a result yeah
which is kind of the same coming out of
different ways getting the same fact so
some would say therefore we should
discard the Multiverse because we cannot
and now in principle ever know whether
it exists so discard it whereas the
theorist would say no that's a mistake
that's a mistake just because we we're
not able to observe it doesn't mean it
doesn't exist maybe it's beyond our
level of comprehension or the capacity
of our instruments but we can't observe
it because it is the product of what
we're saying so that's the tension it's
a it's philosophical but it becomes very
significant where are you on that if you
the the hypothetical case you've come to
the end of the line you cannot know
whether or you're sure that you cannot
measure uh output from the Multiverse
is it oh is it still allowed to be a a
legitimate discussion in science if it's
if it's determined by uh by theoretical
results but it cannot in principle be
accessed right so there's a couple of
questions there I think one one thing to
note is uh is that I don't necessarily
know that it is in the purview of
cosmologists to account for the origin
event of the universe and and its place
within the Multiverse any more than a
biologist has to under uh stand and
explain the origin of life I I don't
think it it would be great I personally
would like to understand it and even if
I was a biologist and I'm not a
biologist and they still don't
understand the origin of life so all the
more so I would like to understand the
origin of the universe however on a
practicing you know kind of standpoint
the the the the attribution that there
is no way to test the Multiverse I think
that's disputed people do claim that not
only is it possible by a preponderance
if you like of circumstantial evidence
okay so but there are actually claims
that we there are observable signals in
the cosmic ray background distinct from
the bmos nothing to do with the Beamon
polarization that I study with the
Simon's Observatory that you would see a
certain type of pattern in the microwave
sky that would be indicative and only
indicative of a Multiverse so-called
bubble Collision a collision with
another Universe problem is and these
are eminent cosmologists that predict it
or make models of this the problem is we
don't know when that would happen that
could be the next Universe over as you
know Philip K dick would say you know
it's a great Universe it's just one
light year over okay so we have to wait
one year what if it's a billion years
what if a billion light years away what
if it's a trillion like we have no
knowledge of its existence we have no
knowledge of its of its uh position
within the Multiverse this other
Universe
um so that but it but it strictly
speaking there are attempts to explain
observationally or to detect the
Multiverse leaving those aside what if
we don't right okay that's where I go
through right so
um I think again I'm sometimes dismayed
by the by the kind of ambivalence of my
students to these questions that it
doesn't trouble them and I think maybe
they get that for me and maybe I'm just
not that good a teacher or or maybe
that's just their disposition I am
fascinated by these ultimate issue type
questions of existence of of purpose of
meaning is It ultimately meaningless as
Stephen Weinberg says the more it's
comprehensible the more or it seems
pointless and and you know he more than
some other people was responsible from
predictions of things like dark energy
which have consequences pertinent to the
Multiverse so
um I think the trouble comes in when we
start looking for atelios you know we
start thinking is there a purpose to the
Multiverse um rather than saying it's
unobservable just as the event Horizons
interior is unobservable or quarks have
you ever seen a quark I even take it
further have you ever seen a triangle no
you've never seen a triangle you've seen
things in a triangular Arrangement but
furthermore the problem that I have and
I don't think the Multiverse proponents
have been as forthright as their
antagonist is in the concept of what why
is it that the laws of physics but
perhaps not the laws of logic or the
laws of philosophy why should those not
vary from multi you know with Universe
to Universal than the Multiverse in
other words we hear often that the that
the constants of nature will vary why
not modus tollens why not modus
pollinate
so then I think all hope is lost if you
couldn't say that mathematics and logic
holds then I think we'd be in
philosophical deep water if we knew for
sure the Multiverse I think that's a
um a kind of mixing ways of thinking
that just because you have different
laws of physics in a Multiverse which is
certainly possible I don't think that
leads to the conclusion of different
laws of logic right it may not I mean
the vacuum state of in the string
landscape interpretation of the model
you know remember they're multiple
multiverses right there's ever ready and
quantum mechanical multiverses there's
there's strength
multiverses of Multiverse
um right so it's hard to pin that down I
think it's a fascinating question it
doesn't fill me with dread it fills me
with excitement and maybe that's because
I'm an experimentalist and I do
sometimes take solace in the fact that I
can shut up and build stuff in my lab